au canada en 2016 14% de la population
de 15 ans et plus vivait seul et c'est
au québec que la proportion était la
plus élevée 18 % de la population
bon évidemment invités seuls ça veut pas
automatiquement dire souffrir de
solitude ou d'isolement social les
tuyaux d'autres facteurs qui sont plus
révélateur est encore là le québec se
distingue en 2013 soit la dernière étude
de statistique canada sur le sujet 8 %
des québécois disent n avoir aucun ami
proche
ces deux points de pourcentage de plus
que pour l'ensemble du pays seulement la
moitié des québécois avait plus de dix
connaissance contrairement à 60 % des
canadiens mais sur le plan des liens
familiaux le québec faisait meilleure
figure
59 % des québécois communiquer avec des
membres de leurs familles quelques fois
par semaine ou plus contre 54 % pour
l'ensemble des canadiens pour essayer de
mieux comprendre ces données on est allé
rencontrer trois personnes qui
s'intéressent de près à la question de
la solitude
la professeure de sociologie cécile van
de velde qui a écrit sur le sujet le
docteur marc et juno qui se préoccupe de
l'impact et isolement social sur la
santé et la député solidaire catherine
dorion comment vous parler de culture de
solitude du fait de la lutte contre la
solitude une des priorités de son mandat
est-ce que c'est surprenant de voir les
indicateurs de solitude qui sont aussi
élevées au québec
non pas du tout c'est la tendance
générale dans toutes les sociétés
occidentales en ce moment on voit que la
solitude est en train d'augmenter et ce
qui est nouveau c'est qu'elle n'augmente
pas uniquement chez les personnes âgées
chez les aînés on la voit de plus en
plus à l'âge adulte est de plus en plus
chez les jeunes chez les adolescents
chez les jeunes adultes en lien
notamment et les nouvelles technologies
qui font une forme de contrôle social de
pression et on voit que les sentiments
solitude chez les jeunes augmente
énormément également mais pas ses amis
j'ai beaucoup de patients qui sont très
seuls soit physiquement ce soit qui se
sentent seuls c'est pas du tout à ce qui
peut être surprenant c'est que je pense
qu'en général on a une image du québec
comme étant plutôt communautaire du côté
latin puis évidemment aujourd'hui les
gens croient plus tellement en dieu mais
l'héritage catholique de la paroisse le
monde ensemble et femmes et les grosses
familles on a cette image lemay
moi je suis convaincu que le modèle
économique aux politiques qui a frappé
de plein fouet depuis les années 80 au
fait des ravages
extrêmement rapide dans les liens entre
une est-ce que collectivement on devrait
s'en préoccupe le plus c'est sûr
complètement
oui moi je crois que c'est un enjeu
social majeur alors la solitude a fait
partie aussi notre condition humaine
on peut pas lutter contre toutes nos
petites solitude
on va vivre tout au long de nos vies
mais il ya certaines formes de solitude
plus fort plus radical contre lesquels
qui deviennent un vrai problème de
société et surtout un enjeu de santé
publique en fait c'est du même ordre que
fumer est trop proche alors ça multiplie
le risque par deux à trois fois de
mentalité précoce selon elle était
prématuré toutes sortes de complications
autant cardiovasculaires que dans
d'autres domaines mais au plan
cardiovasculaire c'est clair pour vivre
mieux et en santé juste une façon faut
éviter lizano sociale on ne voit pas en
général de gens très âgés en bonne santé
ce on devrait parler plus de solitude
parce que c'est la chose la plus
importante pour les humains d'être 1000
cc je veux dire ton grand pas peu dire
ça ma venue de tours une conversation un
peu intense la seule chose qui compte
c'est l'amour c'est les gens qui
t'aiment peut on dire oui ce sont des
rythmes mais après ça on en discute pas
un espace public pourquoi beaucoup plus
important c'est beaucoup plus profond
que que d'avoir 100 pièces de plus par
année comme jésus-christ honnêtement
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour réduire
le nombre de personnes 10 ans
il faut site de free des services qui
multiplie les interactions avec les gens
alors que ce soit des déclins
des rencontres organisées l'austérité
crede a solitude parce que l'austérité a
tendance à baisser tout tous les
financements pour les organismes
communautaires et aujourd'hui les
meilleurs lutte contre la solitude sont
ultra locale
elles sont au niveau des villages au
niveau des communes au niveau des
quartiers oui c'est le temps mieux de
finance par exemple il existe un
programme qui sort les personnes aînées
de la solitude et c'est extraordinaire
ça fait des miracles mais c'est un
plaster que moi je pense que pour qu'on
soit moins seul il faut qu'on recrée des
communautés dans la réalité c'est un
groupe jeune et ça peut pas être juste
une politique comme ça sans rien changer
de tout le système qui nous a divisés
nous atomisé qui nous a dit la seule
chose qui compte pas l'amour c'est le
travail